- Every once in a while at the show,
we like to head outside to
meet up with our friends
for a socially distant chat
we call a Drive-Interview.
(audience cheers)
♪ Drive Interview ♪
(Kelly sings)
That's my favorite one.
Recently I caught up with NASCAR superstar
Kurt Busch, which isn't easy
to do 'cause he's really fast,
do you get it? 'Cause
NASCAR. I know you get it.
Check it out!
(audience laughs)
(guitar music)
(rock music)
(car engine revs)
(tires screech)
All right, all right!
Okay, that's rad.
(both chuckle)
You just rolled up here
looking like that. Okay.
Wow.
- [Kurt] Hi Kelly!
- This was the raddest! You win, you win-
Is this the real deal?
- I had to make an entrance.
Yes, this is an old race car.
When we have the race cars,
they turn into show cars
afterwards, we don't quite put
them out in the pastures.
- That's seriously so badass.
- Thank you.
- This is the coolest one yet.
Have, have cars always been your thing?
- My dad had race cars in the
garage and then street rods.
- Wow.
- And so,
every time we went to the track,
like as a kid, it was a way of life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mark] And so whether
it was Friday or Saturday night,
it was to go see Dad race,
and so that's how I grew up.
- Wow. Was there, I don't
know, any pressure since your
Dad was such a car guy and into
that? Was there any pressure
the first time behind the wheel with him?
- There was, I, I felt like
when we went to the track,
he was there to win.
He didn't make friends,
he was just there to win. And
so, when I was growing up,
like it was a perfectionist
feel with cars.
And so I'm like fifteen and a
half, got my learners permit,
and he's teaching me how
to drive and he's like,
all right, pull into the bank right now.
I pull in and things start
hucky-puckying around
and I stall it.
And I was devastated 'cause
I just wanted to be perfect
for my Dad, especially with cars.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I heard that your wife is a
polo player, which first of all,
I don't know that I've
ever met a polo player.
So like that's pretty cool
but do you ride horses?
- I'm not so good on the horses.
But, I can come back strong.
She's not so good on the go-carts.
But I love to support her polo and
the feel of the team
camaraderie and the competition,
it's very, very equal to the racing world.
With competition, your
horses, the saddles, the cars,
the equipment.
- Yeah, I love the
sound of horses running.
- [Mark] Yes.
- [Kelly] Like I think its the
coolest sound in the world.
I, and I, man, like your
children have to competitive.
(both chuckle)
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] Like there's no
way they're not going to be
with Mom and Dad.
- They can choose what they want to do
but it's going to end up being that way.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
I have been to so many NASCAR
events, and I will tell you
I feel like a lot of the NASCAR think,
obviously the driving is
the epicenter of it all,
but it's like a country
music festival to me.
It's like people come for
the music but they also come
for like the get together. It's
like a giant family kind of
environment. Everybody's
into it, drinking,
having a good time. Like,
are you excited about the
new season, that people are
actually going to be there?
- Yeah last year with COVID and the break
that we went through,
all the new protocols were
put in place to create
the bubble. And to protect
the teams, the drivers, and-
- Which is important.
- Yes, and the officials,
everybody, and the fans.
And now with things starting
to trickle back into place,
we're getting that feel
of our fans coming back,
I mean the first race back,
it was like the twilight zone.
We didn't have the
tailgating, we didn't have the
camaraderie and the
partying going on before,
leading up into the race. And
then after the race it was
eerie. Like the guy won,
he's in victory lane and-
we're all like what is going on?
So we miss the soul of our fans.
- Thank you so much. I'm
such a fan, you're like
even cooler in person. And
I'm so excited for y'all
to get back to this season and
have like fans in the stands
and it becoming more of a norm again.
- Thank you. No, this environment,
right now, just sitting
in our cars and enjoying a conversation.
That's what people do at the tracks.
And our fans are coming back,
the states are opening
up a little bit. But,
of course we all have to
be safe and we'll have our
full capacity yet to come.
- Yeah. Absolutely. Well, small steps.
- Tune in all right? If you
can't be there in person,
you gotta tune in.
- Yeah. I will tune in.
- All right, here we go.
We'll see you on the flip side.
- All right, later!
- You got it.
- Bye!
(woman chuckles)
(audience claps)
- Well I love Kurt Busch.
So I got a new friend,
I love him so much and hey
Kurt please tell your wife
Ashley thank you so much for the gift.
She makes these really
bathing suits y'all.
Monarch Reign. They are
so cute. And I love it.
And I look really good in
it. So thank you Ashley.
But y'all can keep up
with Kurt Busch on the
NASCAR cup series all season long.
Check your local listings for race times.